[Music]
this is Bearcat son as my job is chief
to protect us and one day when you're
all growing up that job will be passed
on to you I'm out there beyond the
sunset lies the home of the Dragon
and I believe is your destiny to one day
find this hidden world so that people
and Dragons will fight no more there
were dragons when I was a boy where they
went only a few know our story changed
the world forever
we did it the world's first dragon
Viking utopia Julia don't be a baby
Mike slay spended and more Oh sanity hey
wait up he's not the only one she's a
light fury oh sorry did he just
disappear
Wow
it's a hidden dragon worth
toothless go introduce yourself has a
girlfriend I've hunted every Night Fury
except yours and him over I will never
give him up then I will destroy
everything you love
we are no longer safe here we all have
to disappear completely off the map we
have to fight for their freedom you
don't nothing without you a dragon
show them what you got but
[Music]
if you and me bud always
[Music]
[Music]